it was absolute pandemonium everywhere
you look
our military vehicles just bristling
with weapons these things can get very
very nasty very quickly for certain
something bad is about to happen
they're so determined to not lose their
evolution they will be a good idea even
her life
[Applause]
the Sudan is a beautiful country it has
an awful olive oil and it could be
really rich
it's just been mismanaged for a very
long time it had many many Wars its
habits as divisions of the country at
the corruption but I think outright
stealing by the regime have made the
economy tank completely and so a sort of
growing youth movement has begun with
demonstrations specifically against the
government to thermal shear President
Omar al-bashir had been in charge of
sedan for three decades
he's an indicted war criminal he's known
for the horrific crimes that we carried
out in Darfur but he was considered
pretty much by everyone as a punching I
can't recall in recent times an uprising
like this people started taking to the
streets as soon as they did there was a
massive metric crackdown and many many
people were killed a lot of people
thought that the protest would just be
shut down after a week maybe two weeks
people were shot and killed it continued
people were injured it continued these
pockets built and built and built and
the numbers swelled there was a sense
that the international community didn't
give a damn about what was going on
Sudan and it wasn't a case we were awful
lot of pressure from people we knew in
the country to come out please come you
know you got it
so we try we're trying every moment that
we had almost got visas to go to the
country there were security with
intervened and to say now the country is
very closed off that were resistant to
outside press the best you could hope
for was social media it was really hard
to watch this all unfolding news came
through right the military had taken
over and Bashir the president actually
got that was quite a moment because then
you you think like things are really
happening things are changing now but
that's a very dodgy time to enter a
country often these things can get very
very nasty very quickly the information
came through actually it's possible we
will be able to sort this out and that
you need to get yourselves ready to go
there's always that little knot of
anxiousness in your picture you have in
your belly when you're going to
something like that look at potentially
turn
[Music]
as soon as you get off the plane
everywhere you look
our military vehicles just bristling
with weapons
this wasn't a peacekeeping force I mean
they were so heavily on we don't know if
they're supporting the demonstrators we
don't know if they're against the
demonstrators you think to yourself this
is gonna go one of two ways
your instinct is to start filming
straight away but these guys are
everywhere I started to very gingerly
lift the camera up and try and sneak a
few shots here and there and engage the
reaction you don't want to be detained
by any part of military intelligence or
any military in Sudan as you can
seriously avoid it you just have to go
by your wits I suppose inexperience and
hope not to be lifted just because you
were actually filming some people
thought that after toppling over
shooting down everything would go quiet
we had one of the protest leaders
Mohammed Nagi in our vehicle with us and
so you know he's guys of the protest
site the demonstrators the protesters
security allowed us through no problem
but I did notice there's quite a lot of
soldiers sort of standing around one of
them we could see him start looking at
as under Ritchie is definitely filming
within a few seconds the soldier comes
over for certain something bad is about
to happen
maybe
they're all speaking in Arabic I
couldn't really tell what was going on
but it's clear it was very clear that he
was not impressed with me having pointed
the camera him okay
since Stuart you know is starting to get
a bit tense and then he he decides that
he really has taken exception
[Music]
I'm next thing the back door opens and
he's this guy with a Kalashnikov across
his chest he's in there and sat behind
me he decides while eating to take us to
military intelligence a place that if
you'd normally go to probably you come
out of if you're lucky days later maybe
never at all the Mostafa good place to
go once we were in the military HQ there
was a load of soldiers in this room and
still didn't know what was going on but
then I start see the odd small crack and
then you can feel detention just going
down I think we're gonna be all right
once they were satisfied with who we
were and what we were doing we were out
and sent on our way normally that would
have been a very very long and difficult
experience you'd have been stuck inside
and probably in an awful lot of trouble
so that was a probably a really good
indicator to us then the things that's
actually different because that would
never have happened just a few years
before few weeks before a few days
before maybe in a few hours before that
would never happen
when we actually finally got into the
protest square as I whoa this is that
this is it this is where the people are
everybody was high on life
and this crowd was just phenomenal here
and everywhere you look to work people
and sometimes they were in groups
chatting sometimes they were singing
sometimes just banging
this was a revolution that had had
success but hadn't ended they wanted a
change they wanted to put their own
people into government they wanted the
militaries to step down to go away
we were amongst the first foreign
journalists to show up at the sites and
people would like are you to tell us
where you found one it's like oh we're
from Ramstein you amazing welcome
welcome and they were slapping Stewart
on the back and shaking Richie's hand
itself er - selfie art - selfie and that
was a brilliant moment just stop for
pictures people actually wanted to
interview you and and and not interest
but just ask your opinion on things
it was difficult to do your job because
everybody wanted to come up and tell you
about it we also you have this thing
where people are trying to help you
right so they're trying to control the
crowd before you know it we're
surrounded by people controlling us
everybody wanted their picture taken so
when ever I pointed my camera take to
get general shots I would have a cluster
of people instantly dive in front of me
and that shot would be just obliterated
oh I remember this one is this where I
was actually trying to make quite a
serious point about what was going on
this revolution should be absolutely
remarkable a couple of days ago you
would have sworn that people would be
jumping all over the place here to keep
restarting and restarting you could get
overwhelmed quite easily while trying to
speak and nobody letting you think
straight you've long enough I'd lose to
it in a crowd I couldn't hear him you
know I just couldn't get a shot and
sometimes we just had to walk away let
it all come down work out what we're
gonna say and then walk in again and
just and then hit the button and go
right and you're gonna get one shot at
it and that was it before the same thing
happened again the ups and downs of this
revolution have been quite remarkable a
couple of days ago you to swirl all
conversation or negotiation was over and
that this was going to turn violent
again I never thought I would see a
crowd and a militia who were the
original Janjaweed dancing and singing
together
who never see people really scared not
dancing miss Olga
[Applause]
I didn't think I was possible that that
would happen because in the past they
had been so scary and and actually so
ruthless and nasty do you never thought
you'd see this right
never
[Music]
but always in the back of your mind
ya know that that's gonna stay like that
[Music]
it only been a very short time period
before it's just a matter of weeks
before this military was firing on its
own people and killing them
gunmen had got themselves into positions
on high-rise block that overlooked
direct me down into whether people were
all gathering the militia who had been
sort of surrounding the crowd actually
then started joining them and started
firing back up at this building and you
concede a firefight taking place I think
that that was a massive change I think
that was the one way you realized okay
and probably when the military said
right this these are these people aren't
going anywhere all throughout the
protest site people would carry posters
of the martyrs as they called it people
who died you'll see sort of shrines to
them on the floor and now up on the
railway bridge where which was the
central focus of the protest
we were so really interested in meeting
the people who'd helped get their
revolution to this point and their
families so I said to one of the guys
were working with it would be really
great to meet one of the families and he
said yeah you know we need to do that
because these people can't be forgotten
one family that we met was a very young
boy Abdul Azim who was killed by the
regime we were introduced to the sister
the brother and the cousin it's
difficult you always have to remember
that these people are going through
probably one of the worst times in their
life and they're allowing you into that
moment into to share it with them
[Music]
what we do his very nature is intrusive
you need to work quickly you need to
work sensitively
[Music]
they had a video clip of the moment
Abdul Azim was killed
they said they had never watched the
video the whole way through it was
heroin and he had faced down the
Sudanese military unarmed and it was
clear that he was unarmed and they
killed him
but I cannot burn the power but the
lemon is the shadow luckiness to Danny
and he'll have at least a enough for the
Hylian of sack by having at least with
them to die Danny LeDonne entirely miss
me her name is a bit redundant doesn't
kind of activity good madam dick but not
one of them thought that the loss of of
Abdul Azim was was a lost it was his
death was worth the revelation but he
explained everything that that's why
there's this this could win this is why
it could be a success because de wardens
thought it was a good idea even if it
cost your lives and that was a very
emotional an environment to see the
younger generation coming up to support
the the revolution is remarkable it's a
youth revolution
[Applause]
one nine particular people had come
fully expecting to have the names of the
new government read out them and people
would like tonight's the night this is
so exciting we want to know who our
government is we name the names of those
people they think it's just this
fantastic rock concert like atmospheres
thousands and thousands of people
crammed in into the this space
people with their phones up and
everywhere you looked around you and it
was absolute pandemonium I was
struggling to see at one stage and these
guys who had clearly been there for
hours were and was standing on these
plastic chairs just stood down and sit
up off your pot and get out there and
I've got the shot and then we want it to
go closer and so I went to hand back and
plastic chairs and he was like no please
take it and we had to make our way
through
through the crowd and everybody was
partying for me and my plastic chair so
that I could get the shots he was great
you could see that they was taking an
awful long time for these people to come
forward you could see it a little
huddled groups on the main stage and
then the sort of addresses to the crowd
became more like do we have to stay on
the streets we have to keep fighting for
the revolution that things aren't going
absolutely perfectly it was pretty
amazing how quickly it switched actually
we eventually sort of extracted
ourselves from the crowds were headed
back to the hotel and there in the radio
in the car was on
and gay lose our producer started
translating this mean that the military
would impose itself on the crowds to dis
mean that they would actually have to go
back to the streets happy to die again
and what will happen next we just didn't
know when we work in foreign countries
we rely so heavily on producers and
journalists who live there and who know
the country better they will ever know
it but of course we come in with our
ideas and and in some cases demand we
want to go and see the military we want
to see the head we want to see the
number two we want to actually go with
the soldiers and you have to be the ones
that are just kept looking at us gay
guys be realist
laymen close themselves off and they're
getting one with whatever it is that
they need to go away
it's just military-style mediated
orientation we keep trying that's why
we're here we're trying to just get to
the bottom of it and perhaps provide
some answers for the people who are all
outside we then had a phone call you say
like get yourselves ready but we're
going to do the leader of the military
council presidential palace lo and
behold they made they made that happen
well we're inside the palace Graham's
now this is the presidential palace and
we've been someone to be given about
five minutes to get here to meet the
head of the military council and we
already told we're late even though he
has found out I'm not really sure what
to expect all or what he's got to say
here we go then we're only quite nervous
is where you're gonna get it right
whether you're gonna mess up into the
air how long's it going to take
Bridget up virtually no time to set it
up these guys don't have if they don't
have a tendency to stay around if things
aren't in place I was sweating that day
it was hard work I think it was quite it
was a lot of pressure and all the while
you've got a C General of the nation
sitting there looking at you gonna come
mate hurry up yeah
the pressures on general do you
guarantee their safety in the coming
days and do you have plans to move them
out or are they free to stay even idea
what are you literally sorrowful oh man
hey Maya had early light if I'm a guard
on by just getting into the presidential
palace by sitting now with the head of
the military council to get him to
answer some basic questions about the
future that of the of the youngsters
uprising it felt oh yeah actually this
could work this actually could work
doesn't mean it will doesn't mean it
won't all just go badly wrong but at
that instant I think we all felt wow
this has moved on and we've been here to
witness they're moving on significantly
[Music]
those last days of us their work was
there was a sudden massive change it was
the bit that we realized we'd come it
had been high it had gone low and they
had gotten really high again and it was
hard to imagine that plateau being
dropped off significantly the military
have reached out they're not gonna form
a council half of the military half of
them civilian and after that they're
gonna make a government the Prime
Minister a Deputy Prime Minister and
cabinet minister so this is a massive
jump because it is these people who will
decide who makes up that government it's
unheard of here for the last thirty
years it's been a military dictatorship
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was very clear that they were
anything but deflated and these people
were not about to give up anytime soon
[Music]
more people were arriving the pictures
were amazing just a sheer volume of
people trucks with people and flags and
singing and chanting the big sort of
human snakes going along with big flags
on top of them and they would come in on
these trains with just thousands and
thousands of people hanging on to them
and joining in a numbers were growing
all the time
that was the moment that was it that was
the sort of everyone around you believe
right the talk to the back on and more
of a Sorrell arriving by the minute so
we're not going to give it it was really
a privilege and felt like a privilege I
kept pinching myself to be here in this
moment that was so important to the next
generation to the younger generation of
Sudanese this moment where they thought
our future is going to change and there
they are so so so determined to not let
it go to not lose their evolution or
maybe won't but I've got you know no
doubt they're going to achieve what
they've set out to the gene because you
know I've not seen determination like
that very often in my career
[Music]
you'd have to be a real skeptic to not
be carried away with the optimism so
said you know I am skeptical enough to
know that this optimism can be not so
much misplaced but it can be mishandled
but everyone acknowledges that they
can't ignore the youth day of bringing
about the change that their parents
weren't able to do they they were
unstuff Lewis er was amazing
[Music]
you
[Music]